In 1965 in one of the most remote locations
on earth six teenagers were enduring a school
day much like any other boys their age.
Well, sort of.
Natives of Tongatapu, the main island of the
Kingdom of Tonga – not only were they trapped
on an itty-bitty idyll in the blue abyss,
they were equally trapped in their strict
Catholic boarding school.
It was a horrid place run by nasty old nuns
who loved nothing more than to hit pupils
over the head with Bibles.
As any feisty fifteen-year-old would, one
day, sick of prayers and Latin they decided
to run away.
Come lunchtime the six-strong gang had gathered
on the beach and “borrowed” a boat from
a grumpy fisherman whom they had a particular
disdain for.
Their plan?
To somehow navigate their tiny vessel to Fiji
to start a new life, hopefully somewhere with
less bastard nuns knocking around.
They packed some bananas, a few coconuts and
a small gas burner.
Amazingly not one of the teens thought to
pack a map or compass, evidently fancying
themselves as little Marco Polos.
Now, I don’t know if you’ve recently checked
the distance between Tonga and Fiji – I
know it’s been a busy year – but let me
remind you, it’s about 474 miles!
So yeah, sans map or compass, I don’t think
much of their chances in this case.
To make matters worse they were all exhausted,
from late-night study sessions and early starts.
So, only a few klicks out from land, they
dropped anchor for the evening and before
they knew it, the gentle rocking
of
the boat sent them
all
to sleep.
When they awoke the weather had turned, and
the violent waves snapped the boat’s sail
and rudder clean off, leaving the group to
drift helplessly for eight days, without food
or water.
They tried catching fish.
They tried collecting rainwater in their hollowed-out
coconut shells, allowing everyone just one
sip in the morning and another in the evening.
With their boat rapidly falling apart it was
only a matter of time before they sank.
But mercifully, on the ninth day, they saw
it: a glimpse of a small, deserted island,
only half a mile squared, with steep cliffs,
rocky beaches and a low-lying coral reef.
They desperately swam ashore, using planks
from the boat for buoyancy.
Exhausted, starving, thirsty, they collapsed
onto the island: little did they know it at
the time, but here these naive teens would
spend their next 15 months.
The boys had drifted an astonishing 200 miles
until they eventually reached the island of
‘Ata.
Now ‘Ata was beautiful, but also completely
barren: it had been uninhabited since 1863,
after slavers evacuated it.
The incredible tale of these six school boys
was only recently discovered by a Dutch author
and historian called Rutger Bregman whilst
researching for his own book, called Humankind:
A Hopeful History.
Bregman tracked down and interviewed the survivors,
and the captain who found them: Peter Warner.
Now Peter was the youngest son of one of the
richest men in Australia, Arthur Warner.
Back in the 1930s Arthur Warner ruled over
a vast empire called Electronic Industries,
which manufactured radios – as the main
source of home entertainment, that was a pretty
big deal back then.
Poor old Peter was under a lot of pressure
to follow in his father’s footsteps.
But Peter, much like the Tongan boys, wasn’t
great at the whole work thing, and so apparently,
like all teenage boys seemed to do back then,
ran away to sea in search of adventure.
He spent the next few years sailing all over
the world, visiting Hong Kong, Stockholm,
Shanghai and St. Petersburg, an extended gap
year, if you will.
He promised his dad he would learn something
sensible like accounting, and although it’s
not exactly clear how he spent his time whilst
travelling, we can be pretty sure it wasn’t
bean counting – more like beer counting.
After Peter’s 5 year long holiday he finally
decided to return home, but still went on
frequent fishing trips for a taste of freedom.
In the winter of 1966 he took a trip to Tonga,
and on his way home made a little detour.
When, lo and behold, what should he stumble
upon but the little old isle of ‘Ata.
However, as Peter passed the island, he noticed
something odd.
Through his binoculars he could see burnt
patches on the cliffs, and thought this was
strange because it was unusual for forest
fires to start spontaneously in this humid
part of the world.
Suddenly, he saw a boy emerge from the bushes,
looking full on Rambo, except probably skinnier.
He was naked, with hair down to his shoulders
and covered in mud.
The boy jumped into the water, and started
swimming towards his boat.
At this point Peter got a bit worried.
At the time criminals were sometimes marooned
on desert islands as punishment, and so he
wasn’t sure if things were actually about
to go full on Rambo, or if he was about to
become somebody’s dinner.
Instead, a scraggly but well-spoken kid came
on board, and said, in perfect English: “My
name is Stephen.
There are six of us and we reckon we’ve
been here 15 months.”
Peter still thought better safe than sorry,
and so radioed back to the capital.
The operator confirmed he had indeed found
the lost boys, who’d been presumed dead
for over a year.
The families had even held funerals for their
missing sons, assuming they’d drowned at
sea.
Captain Warner and Stephen went ashore to
collect the other boys, and Peter was shocked
at what he discovered.
Not only had the boys managed to survive on
the island, but they had actually thrived.
Even in the sixties most teenagers would have
been lost without spam and mostly black and
white television, but these were not ordinary
teenagers.
Growing up on tropical Tonga they possessed
skills more suited to surviving on a small
island.
Warner wrote in his memoirs that “the boys
had set up a small commune with a food garden,
hollowed-out tree trunks to store rainwater,
a gym with weights, a badminton court, chicken
pens and a permanent fire, all from handiwork,
an old knife blade, and much determination.”
I’m not sure what’s more impressive, the
fact they had built a badminton court or that
they had any time to play, given they seemed
to be pretty darn busy.
The six boys had split up into teams of two,
drawing up a strict rota for garden, kitchen
and guard duty, and so were working virtually
all day long.
It would be easy for a bunch of teenagers
to bicker and whine all the time, but the
boys had sussed it out - if they ever started
to argue, they had a strict ‘time-out policy’,
where they would spend four hours alone to
cool off.
They kept their spirits up by singing and
praying, and one of the boys even managed
to make a guitar from a bit of driftwood,
half a coconut shell and six steel wires taken
from the boat (I told you they were nifty).
They survived by eating fish, coconuts, birds
and bird-eggs, and even drank the blood of
the animals for extra nutrients.
Three months in, they also discovered the
ruins of a village from when the island had
been inhabited, and found bananas, chickens
and wild taro, an edible plant with giant,
spinach-like leaves.
It wasn’t all smooth-sailing though.
They spent months building a raft only for
it to be smashed to pieces by waves crashing
over the coral reef.
One of the boys also slipped off a cliff and
broke his leg.
By some miracle the other boys managed to
clamber down the cliff and bring him back
up, where they set his legs using sticks and
leaves, but he was unable to work for several
months.
What’s even more remarkable though is what
happened after they got off the island.
Peter took the boys back to Tonga, and just
as they were coming into the harbour, a police
boat arrived.
Were they coming to reward Captain Warner,
or safely deliver the boys to their families?
Nope.
They had arrived to arrest the boys for “borrowing”
the grumpy old man’s boat fifteen months
earlier.
Turns out grumpy old men don’t just like
to shout and wave their walking sticks; they
also like to press charges.
The boys were thrown in jail, and at this
point, may well have been wishing they were
back on the island, where they had more space
and probably better food.
Peter had a plan though.
He knew that the story of their shipwreck
was perfect Hollywood material, and he could
make some money by selling the rights to the
story.
And that’s exactly what he did, using his
family’s connections to flog them to one
of the biggest TV channels in Australia.
Peter paid the grumpy old man back, and got
the boys released as long as they agreed to
co-operate with the movie.
The King of Tonga also rewarded Warner with
the right to trap lobsters and start a fishing
business in the local waters.
Warner used his new privilege to hire the
boys to crew his fishing boat (although you
would’ve thought they might want to spend
some time at home for a change).
It was a win-win situation; Peter didn’t
have to go back to boring old accounting,
and the boys didn’t have to go back to boring
old boarding school.
54 years later, this story has made headlines
all over the world, and the boys have since
been dubbed ‘The Real Lord Of The Flies.’
Now, in case you haven’t read Lord of the
Flies, or like the Tongan boys, prefered to
piss off to Fiji rather than study, let me
give you a quick recap.
The book was written by William Golding in
1954, and tells the story of a group of British
schoolboys who are in a plane crash, and end
up stranded on an uninhabited island.
At first they are super excited because, you
know, no adults, but soon their tale takes
a dark turn.
They fight over who is going to be leader,
they struggle to keep the signal fire going,
and start to become frightened of a mysterious
monster in the jungle, which they call the
‘beast.’
Some of the boys become obsessed with hunting,
and think that if they sacrifice pigs as tributes
to the ‘beast’, it’ll leave them alone.
After a couple of failed attempts they do
eventually manage to kill a pig, and hold
a celebration, where they go full on tribal.
They paint their faces and dance around the
fire whilst chanting “Kill the pig!
Cut its throat!
Spill her blood!” - which is pretty creepy
for a bunch of seven year olds.
The problem is they get so carried away pretending
to be savages that they actually become savages
- in the dark they become so hysterical they
accidentally mistake one of the other boys,
Simon, for the beast, and beat him before
literally ripping him apart limb from limb.
Did I mention this is a children’s book?
Things only get worse from there.
Civil war breaks out and one of the factions
kills another boy, Piggy, by squishing him
under a boulder.
Pretty gruesome, but in boarding school they
probably call that character building.
They let the fire run rampant, almost burning
the whole island down, and they are just ready
to kill another boy, Ralph, when they are
finally saved by a British navy officer who
saw the fire from afar.
The officer comes up to them and simply says
“I should have thought a pack of British
boys would have put up a better show than
that.”
Quite.
Now this story is often used as a metaphor
for the human condition, a visceral argument
for the innately evil nature of human beings.
To be fair to Golding, this was just after
World War Two and the Holocaust, during which
he served as a Lieutenant aboard a Royal Navy
destroyer involved in sinking the Bismark,
so he’d seen, first hand, how wicked human
beings could be to one other.
He was also a schoolteacher, but if that’s
how he thought his pupils behaved in their
spare time, you really have to wonder what
the hell he was teaching.
The thing is though, the story of the Tongan
boys was nothing like the book, and so perhaps
it’s unfair to call them ‘the real Lord
of the Flies’ – they were so much better
than that.
They didn’t kill each other, quite the opposite-
they were actually kind to each other.
What happened on ‘Ata was not about survival
of the fittest, but survival of the friendliest.
But how did such a hopeful, heart-warming
story go unheard of for so long?
It’s not as if people aren’t interested
in stories about desert island survival – think
about Lost, Shipwrecked, Castaway, or books
like Robinson Crusoe.
Well, Bregman, the historian who wrote about
the Tongan boys for his book, has one theory
– that people are simply not that interested
in stories with happy endings.
Bregman argues that stories with pleasant
messages are overlooked in favour of stories
about conflict and trauma, which isn’t hard
to believe when you look at the daily news.
Newspapers and TV broadcasts are filled with
disaster, corruption and incompetence – it’s
all rather depressing.
Mind you, if the news reported every time
a train doesn’t explode, it’d take longer
than your morning coffee to get through the
headlines.
Science says there's a good reason for all
this doom and gloom – humans are fundamentally
wired with a negativity bias.
I’ve covered why this is on the channel
not too long ago, but in short, evolution
has programmed our brains to always favour
negative events.
That’s why it’s so important to celebrate
stories like these though.
They provide hope in humanity, which is increasingly
rare in these strange and uncertain times.
Despite the pessimism peddled by Golding in
Lord of The Flies, I like to believe that
when the chips are down, most people are hard-wired
to help rather than harm each other.
And those brave Tongan boys give me some hope
that may just be true.
Thanks for watching.